I'm living my best life yeah which is
always a beautiful white woman uh
pampering herself it's like living your
best life is not helping somebody out
they're never in like a soup kitchen
wearing red bottom high heels it's never
that it's always there at a spa you know
drinking something and it's it's like
well that's a better life than the soup
kitchen though
you'd rather be at a spa well shouldn't
your best life be like you're not being
a douche and you you're a better person
but it's not a better best life is
pampering yourself that for that's
probably for her is a better life yeah
yeah maybe I'm just old I just look at
it going like that's like [__] gross
that's your best life rather than being
like hey man I'm [__] having a good
time I don't even like vacation like
vacation photos bother me too it's just
like what if I took a picture of myself
in a cigar bar living my best life
I mean I would immediately be an [__]
I just don't yeah who says it about
yourself I I yeah that's that to me
that's the weird thing announcing that
it's your best because where do you go
from there